we begin tonight with the news that
pushed the midterms off the front page
the resignation of Jeff Sessions
all right sessions departure comes less
than two years after he angered trumped
by recusing himself from the Russia
probe the president has repeatedly
expressed his frustration over that
original decision to recuse now stepping
in his acting Attorney General is Matt
Whittaker he's a former US Attorney from
Iowa who is serving now or was as
sessions chief of staff now Trump is
said to have a very strong personal
rapport with Whittaker who at least for
now
will oversee the Muller probe and the
rest of the DOJ business which includes
by the way do J's other federal
investigations including those New York
prosecutors were looking into the
finances of the president and his former
aides now for what this AG resignation
could mean we're joined now by former US
Attorney Joe digenova who's not in the
studio so Satterlee former assistant US
attorney and Fox News contributor Andy
McCarthy and George twilliger former DOJ
Deputy Attorney General who actually
became an acting AG himself now Joe
let's start with you
Democrats are already calling for
Whitaker to recuse himself because of
his past statements on another network
he was a contributor and he made some
comments about the Muller probe and
writing we'll get to some of them in a
moment but your reaction well those
previous comments are not recusant Balam
ents mr. Whitaker is a fine person he is
completely independent he knows about
the administration of this particular
case I am delighted that supervision of
this case has been taken away from
Deputy Attorney General Rosen Stein in
light of his conduct and I think that
mr. Whitaker will handle this fine the
Democrats are doing what they always do
when they don't have anything else they
just start screaming and yelling this is
an embarrassment to them but it's going
to continue and mr. Whitaker is going to
be just fine
George want to go to you since you were
acting AG and I remember now I had
forgotten
so Schumer today said the following
George he said given his previous
comments advocating defunding and
imposing limitations on the Muller
investigation mr. Whittaker should
recuse himself from its oversight for
the duration of his time as Acting
Attorney General and and just so people
know what we're talking about I want to
play this soundbite from mark Whitacre
now this George was from CNN and it was
back in July of 2017 let's take a look
watch well I can see a scenario where
Jeff Sessions is replaced it was a
recess appointment and that attorney
general doesn't fire Bob Mahler but he
just reduces the budget so low that his
his investigation grinds to it
absolutely almost no different life he
was working for a network grounds for
recusal no I mean two to two quick
points Laura one if every time a lawyer
made comments about some matter of
public interest and then later got
involved they and would have to recuse
himself poor Joe for example wouldn't be
able to practice law but but secondly
your point is well the fact of the
matter this was a different time a
different set of facts and I'm sure Matt
will make his decisions in this case
based on whatever circumstances he
becomes aware of so and just for our
viewers edification here as acting
Attorney General you have all the powers
of the Attorney General correct you just
simply haven't gone through Senate
confirmation and it's thought to be
temporary could it be indefinite well
there's under the vacancies Act there'll
be some limitations of time and Matt
can't be nominated to succeed to his own
position while he's in the position and
there are a couple of exceptions such as
he can't sign Pfizer's oh okay now this
is getting very interesting all right we
got to go to Andy here John Brennan your
favorite Andy was out today and Joe
sorry Joe's favorite was out today of
course banging the same recusal drum
that George was just referencing let's
watch Brennan and company Matt Whittaker
comes with a lot of baggage and it's
going to be quite
evidence I think whether or not he is
going to fulfill his responsibilities
now in that position are you saying that
mr. Whittaker with his public statements
public writings and his comments on
television should be recused from
overseeing the Millar probe based on
those statements I would think that
there is a very strong case that given
his public acknowledgement of his
prejudiced view on this issue that he
should recuse themselves Andy Moore
recusal talk it's what they pushed
sessions into doing and I know there's a
debate about that I still say sessions
didn't have to recuse himself but he
rushed to recuse himself a lot of
pressure put on him and he will tada
under it in my view but is there is
there really legitimate grounds here for
a former commentator to have to recuse
here no Laura I looked very carefully at
what he said when he was at CNN I'll
actually have a column up about this at
National Review tomorrow he didn't say
anything that was in the nature of
recusal commentary he didn't make any
pre judgments about the investigation he
didn't say anything to denigrate what
Muller is up to and what I find
fascinating and I'm not casting
aspersions I want to be clear on Deputy
Attorney General Rosen Stein's ethics
but I haven't heard any of these guys
complaining that Rosenstein is
overseeing this investigation
notwithstanding that Muller is
investigating supposedly Trump for
obstructing the investigation by firing
Comey a transaction in which Rosenstein
is a key player so if there's anybody in
this equation that has a screaming
conflict of interest its rod Rosenstein
and I haven't heard these guys say a
word about that all right Joe I have to
ask you on picks for attorney general
we all have maybe a couple ideas what
are your ideas well I have a couple of
ideas which I've shared with the press
and I'm not going to share them with
anybody else so if I say any of my ideas
I will be sharing a conversation with
the president so can you give us a bowl
and you know if we do fortune I mean my
gosh this is so frustrating
now everybody's gonna okay yep forget it
y'all there are plenty there are plenty
of great people there are plenty of
great sample that's such an
uncharacteristically vague answer from
Joe Genova he's always going right in
for the day all right - Williger couple
ideas come on just throw it out this is
a fun conversation we don't know well I
agree with Joe there's lots of great
people out there than I the only one is
gonna give the president any advice here
on who should be okay Andy do you have
any other than Andy and Joe and George
Andy Joe George would you take it if he
asked you would you do it no Laura I I
don't need to be on the signature line
I'm content to not be in the caption
under where it says US versus my look
George - Williger and Joe - Genevieve
been at the top of every single list of
this question every single time I've
ever been asked it and the boy could the
president ever do a lot worse yeah so we
got your Williger on the list I was just
trying to hint around this Andy you gave
it away all right so you got you got Joe
on the list you got two Williger on the
list I'm gonna yes you are all right I'm
gonna make a suggestion and just to
throw it out there you can all criticize
it attack it's fine
I'm gonna make a suggestion of Chris
Christie I'm gonna tell you why okay I
think there are a number of reasons why
Christie would be good and we might have
him out of order if we have a graphic
but number one he has about an 18-year
personal relationship with the president
they get along they know each other
he has already walked through the media
fire he knows what it's like to be in
the bright white spotlight of the New
York media and frankly the national
media I think temperamentally he and
Trump are similar I mean they're they
get along as people they have kind of a
similar style I don't think that's a
detriment in this job whatsoever he was
known as the toughest nails prosecutor
very well respected by career
prosecutors at DOJ I think you know the
Bridgegate I don't think any of that
matters I think with the with the number
of Republicans we have now in the Senate
Christie would get confirmed if the
president said this is the guy I want I
think Chris Christie would get confirmed
I don't think it would be much of a
problem and I don't think the beach
photo the beach closure is this could
not come out of it okay that's my view
all right come on Joe give me some
thoughts on that Christie chris Christie
would be fine he's experienced he's
smart he's intelligence he would have
the full confidence of the President of
the United States which is to me what
was missing from the relationship with
Jeff Sessions the president is entitled
to have a full-time Attorney General and
Christie could fulfill that role very
nicely Andy McCarthy what about Christie
now I've had my policy disagreements
with him but he no one can question his
credentials I'd be worried that the
Bridgegate thing would be more of a
problem than I think you're calculating
because I think they'd try to relitigate
that whole thing litigate it if the
president said look he's my guy I know
him he's not gonna wilt under pressure
he's not gonna go recusal recusal recuse
me it's not gonna do that
plus he has actually good relationship
with Muller right I mean he's not a good
relationship he respects Mahler he's not
been on TV saying it's a you know it's a
witch-hunt which i think would be a
problem for him becoming Attorney
General he's been quite I think
dispassionate in his overall analysis
Andy yeah no look all that's true I I
just think I probably think it would be
more of a problem than you do in terms
of the way it would play out at a
confirmation hearing but I do think he'd
be confirmed and I think he'd do a good
job by the way
yeah and by the way his lawyer his
lawyer in Bridgegate
was Christopher Rea okay the tangled
tentacles all around sorry let you go
what what do the Republicans have in
store in the House of Representatives
with a subpoena power all these very
anxious Democrats
out of power for a while tax returns
monuments clause business dealings
they're itching for it yeah it's it has
the promise of getting really ugly and
and I think the White House is going and
the administration in general are going
to have to make some very hard decisions
about where what what things defy when
to fight and how to fight but they're
gonna have to fight well and again
that's Christie's a fighter I mean
anyone has seen his old press
conferences from New Jersey of some
among the most entertaining but he does
it's really smart that's true and he's
also I mean I think it's really
important that somebody at the top of
the Justice Department particularly with
these issues actually be a real
prosecutor and knows what it's all about
and that's I think that was a deficit
was it not Joe for for Jeff Sessions and
Jeff session I think it's a very nice
person he's phenomenal on so many of the
issues that Trump cares about and was
great I love what he's doing on on the
marijuana thing I'm with him on that but
he knows temporary temperament versus
real nuts and bolts experiment well and
and he had another problem and that is
that the president insists on people who
have command presence that is certainly
something which Chris Christie would
bring to the job and with robert muller
spending more than thirty eight million
dollars to produce absolutely nothing by
way of russian collusion Christie would
be the perfect overseer of that
monstrosity and now before we let you go
Andy does the Muller investigation how
do you see it developing at this point
with the change of sessions oh I think
it's probably pretty ripe I think
Muller's toward the end of what he's
doing anyway but I'm I love that you
want a a wartime consul yerry
you bet I go for the Italians okay the
Italian mind says I mean that what we
like to Irish to Joe did I pronounce
that right Joe yes yes you did it by the
way father my god if you never watch
Godfather 1 and to the best movies ever
made
alright guys fantastic thank you so much
for your insight and George is great to
have you out will you come back I love
today better than Joe and Andy oh I'm
just kidding alright for more on white
rum won and how the GOP could do it
again remember get my copy of my new
paperback you're gonna love it busing
the barricades what I saw at the
populist revolt in bookstores everywhere
and come